saludos en este vídeo vamos a hablar de
crecimiento logístico aunque les
recomiendo que primero vean el vídeo
sobre crecimiento exponencial el
crecimiento logístico es el que ocurre
después de esto es decir después de que
una población colapsa o alcance el
límite de la capacidad de carga natural
de cierta región primero hablemos del
crecimiento de población en general
imaginemos que tenemos dos conejos así
que el valor de ms-dos n siempre indica
el tamaño de la población que va a
cambiar con el tiempo pero en este
momento es de dos r nos indica la
rapidez con la que va a cambiar la
población le llamaremos tasa de
crecimiento y está determinada por dos
cosas nacimientos y muertes
digamos que estos dos conejos tienen dos
conejos bebés así que tenemos dos
nacimientos -0 muertes lo que nos da 2
-0 que es igual a 2 lo dividimos entre
la n original de 2 que nos da 2 entre 2
o 1
y si tenemos una tasa de crecimiento de
1 las cosas van a crecer muy rápidamente
aunque podríamos tener una tasa de
crecimiento de punto 5 por ejemplo
podemos tener dos nacimientos y uno
muere por lo que son dos menos uno nos
da 1 entre 2 nos da punto 5 lo que
debemos recordar sobre el crecimiento
exponencial es que si r es mayor a 0
tendremos un crecimiento exponencial
rápido digamos que nuestra tasa de
crecimiento es 1 lo que va a pasar es
que estos cuatro conejos se convertirán
en 8 y luego tomaremos estos ocho y los
multiplicaremos por la tasa de
crecimiento de uno y ahora tendremos 16
luego tendremos 32 después 64 después
128 luego 256 y muy pronto la pantalla
se llenará de conejos lo que le costará
trabajo procesar a mi computadora esto
ocurre en la naturaleza
darwin se dio cuenta de esto aunque él
observó elefantes en lugar de conejos y
a diferencia de los conejos a los
elefantes les toma mucho tiempo
reproducirse deben tener al menos 30
años antes de poder reproducirse darwin
nos dice el elefante es considerado el
animal que se reproduce más lentamente
de todos los animales me ha causado
algunas molestias calcular la tasa
mínima probable de su aumento natural
podemos suponer que se reproduce cuando
tiene 30 años y lo continúa haciendo
hasta que tiene 90 dando lugar a tres
pares de crías si fuese así al final del
quinto siglo habría vivos 15 millones de
elefantes descendientes de la primera
pareja así que pueden ver que el
crecimiento exponencial es muy rápido y
sabemos que no puede durar para siempre
ya que eventualmente se llegará a un
límite
veamos de nuevo a estos cuatro conejos
eventualmente llegaremos a un límite
llamado clan o capacidad de carga que es
la máxima cantidad de población que un
área o ecosistema puede soportar a qué
se debe esto bueno los conejos comen
cosas como pasto y cuando se les acaba
el pasto se mueven y aquí no tengo bien
la proporción debemos poner más
productores que consumidores y pongamos
a nuestros conejos en el pasto y lo que
van a hacer es comer el pasto por lo que
el pasto se va a acabar y ellos irán a
otra área en donde afortunadamente hay
pasto pero eventualmente quedarán
rodeados de áreas sin pasto por ejemplo
este conejo de aquí está en problemas
porque si el pasto no crece no tendrá a
dónde ir si tuviéramos más de cuatro
conejos habríamos excedido la capacidad
de carga en clase les pido a mis
estudiantes que construyan modelos que
muestran el crecimiento logístico
muchos usan lápiz y papel pero un grupo
creativo uso minecraft ellos
con un pequeño contenedor y adentro
pusieron una gallina y cada vez que esta
gallina toca una de estas plataformas se
abren dos puertas y entran dos gallinas
más por lo que tenemos tres gallinas y
cuando ellas pisan las plataformas muy
pronto tendremos cinco gallinas y en
poco tiempo habrá gallinas por doquier
yo les pedí a mis estudiantes que
mostrarán un crecimiento logístico y mis
brillantes estudiantes dijeron que
eventualmente esto se llena tanto que
las gallinas que están sobre las
plataformas ya no pueden dejar de pisar
las y entonces ya no pueden entrar más
gallinas en el contenedor de manera que
en ese momento se alcanzó la capacidad
de carga ahora permítanme mostrarles
otro modelo este es el modelo de net
logo llamado conejos pasto maleza
vamos a ejecutarlo en este modelo los
conejos son estas cosas blancas con
orejas y el pasto serán estos cuadros
verdes comenzaremos con 5 conejos ellos
tratarán de encontrar pasto y si lo
encuentran obtendrán energía
tienen suficiente energía podrán
reproducirse pero si no encuentran pasto
morirán lo dejamos correr un momento y
vemos que aumenta muy rápidamente veamos
qué ocurre la línea roja representa el
número de conejos en el tiempo
comenzamos con 5 y en poco tiempo ya
tenemos 350 conejos que le pasó al pasto
comenzó a reproducirse también pero
colapsa porque los conejos se comieron
todo el pasto veamos qué sucede si no
dejamos correr un poco más hay una gran
caída en la cantidad de conejos que
finalmente alcanzará un límite se
llegará a la cantidad perfecta de
conejos que pueden existir y aquí
decimos que alcanzó la capacidad de
carga pueden ver que si dejamos que esto
siga corriendo tanto el pasto como los
conejos van a aumentar y a disminuir
pero se mantendrán dentro de dicho
límite ahora digamos que le damos mayor
energía al pasto para que haya mayor
energía en él veremos de nuevo un
crecimiento exponencial y tendremos una
mayor cantidad de conejos
decimos que el pasto tendrá menos
energía veremos que tenemos menos
conejos por lo que la población de
conejos disminuyó y tendrá también su
propia capacidad de carga así que cuando
aumenta la población vemos que nos
encontramos con estos factores
limitantes que van a disminuir el
crecimiento terminamos la simulación y
ahora veamos las matemáticas sigamos el
crecimiento exponencial esta será su
ecuación de n sobre dt que es el cambio
en n entre el cambio en el tiempo y será
r multiplicada por n r es la tasa de
crecimiento y n es el tamaño de la
población si comenzamos como lo hicimos
con el crecimiento exponencial iniciamos
con dos conejos y nuestro cambio en n
entre nuestro cambio en t será de 2 como
lo obtuvimos multiplicando r que
recordamos es 1 por n que es 2 y tenemos
un 2 este cambio nn me va a dar mi nueva
población tenemos este 2 de la población
inicial y les 1 este 2 y nos da nuestra
siguiente población de 4
el cambio en n con respecto al tiempo
para la siguiente generación será r que
es 1 x n que es 4 lo que nos da 4 luego
tendremos 8 después 16 y después 32 si
gráfica mos esto obtendremos una curva
con forma de j pero lo que quiero que
hagan es que vean esta ecuación de acá y
de an como la modificó para que muestre
la capacidad de carga lo único que va a
cambiar es lo que se encuentra en este
paréntesis este es el factor que está
relacionado con la capacidad de carga lo
que voy a hacer es elegir una capacidad
de carga arbitraria digamos que es 10
sienta áreas puede soportar a 10 conejos
veamos qué sucede
comenzamos con dos conejos en el tiempo
cero y veremos qué sucede con lo que
está entre paréntesis acá - n entre acá
acá es nuestra capacidad de carga en
este caso 10 - n que es 2 así que es
menos 2 lo que nos da 8 y nuestra
capacidad de carga es 10
así que tendremos 8 entre 10 lo que nos
da punto 8
ahora vamos a calcular esto es re
dijimos que es 1 por n que es 2 x lo que
está entre paréntesis punto 8 que nos da
1.6 toda esta ecuación nos va a decir
cuántos conejos nuevos vamos a tener y
no vamos a redondear la cantidad veamos
lo que sucede cuando aumentamos esto
nuestra población aumentará en 1.6
conejos veamos el tiempo 1 ahora tenemos
tres puntos seis conejos esto viene de
los dos conejos que teníamos
originalmente más el 1.6 ahora tendremos
en el paréntesis acá que es 10 menos 3.6
lo que nos da 6.4 dividido entre 10 nos
queda punto 64 podemos ver que nos está
dando un número más pequeño vamos a
multiplicar esto por 3.6 de nuevo es 1
por 3.6 y esto lo multiplicamos por
punto 64 y nos
a 2.3 esto lo sumamos al 3.6 que
teníamos antes y tendremos 5.9 ahora
veamos nuestra k menos n entre k será
punto 41 y tendremos 2.4 pueden ver que
conforme aumenta la población este
factor se vuelve cada vez más y más
pequeño ahora solo agregamos 1.4 y
después agregamos solo punto 29 y al
final agregamos puntos 0.09 podemos ver
que n aumenta rápidamente al principio
pero conforme nos acercamos a la
capacidad de carga de la población se va
a equilibrar porque está alcanzando
dicho límite
estas son matemáticas solamente no es un
modelo pero muestra que eventualmente
llegaremos a este límite
en resumen r es la tasa de crecimiento k
es la capacidad de carga recuerden que
si r es mayor que cero tendremos un
crecimiento exponencial y si alguna vez
tenemos acá una capacidad de carga
tendremos un crecimiento logístico
también tenemos especies que se
especializan en estos dos tenemos
especies de selección ere o estrategas
ere y especies de selección acá o
estrategas acá qué significa esto las
especies de selección ere o estrategas
ere son aquellas especies que buscan
crecer tan rápido como puedan vean la
cantidad de bebés que tendrá estas ranas
miles si yo tomara a esta rana y la
pusiera en un estanque en donde no
hubiera ranas tendríamos muchas ranas en
muy poco tiempo vamos a tener una r muy
grande van a llenar esta área se
quedarán sin recursos y colapsaran
tendrán un auge y una caída porque
saturarán su ambiente muy rápido por
otro lado tenemos al camaleón y vean que
este camaleón sólo tendrá dos
descendientes por lo que su tasa de
crecimiento será realmente lenta lo que
el camaleón va a hacer es proporcionar
mucho cuidado parental e invertir a
mucha energía en el cuidado de sus hijos
y todos van a sobrevivir si vemos aquí
arriba a nuestra especie de selección r
la mayoría de los bebés morirán
eventualmente pero ya que el camaleón
cuida mucho a sus hijos todos van a
sobrevivir este tipo de especie va a
aumentar gradualmente y alcanzará una
agradable capacidad de carga qué tipo de
especies somos nosotros los humanos
nosotros invertimos mucho en nuestros
hijos muchos de mis estudiantes tienen
17 años y aún viven en casa de sus
padres y sus padres los cuidan realmente
invierten mucho cuidado en ellos así que
qué tipo de curva de crecimiento veremos
en los humanos tenemos un crecimiento
exponencial gradual y luego una bonita
capacidad de carga que alcanzaremos
eventualmente no queremos tener este
ciclo de auge y caída aunque hay más
variaciones de esto hay especies que se
encuentran entre ambos tipos podemos
pensar en los árboles que crecen
lentamente pero que tienen mucha
descendencia en qué categoría caen
probablemente no haya una respuesta
correcta para esto entonces qué es el
crecimiento logístico es cuando hay un
crecimiento rápido pero que
eventualmente alcanzará una capacidad de
carga con base en limitantes en el medio
espero que esto les haya sido útil